momento de hablar de nuestra revista de
prensa con Marta Moya Marta Buen día
para usted Hola Ángela Buenos días Pues
vamos a comenzar a navegar en los temas
de la prensa internacional eh con un
artículo de Al jazira que está
Rescatando algunos de los casos de rusos
que fueron acusados de fake news por
haber hecho comentarios poco amables
sobre el desempeño de su ejército en
Ucrania si Ángela hemos destacado este
artículo de alzyazira porque según
registros de la Organización de Derechos
Humanos
info al menos
482 personas han sido acusadas desde el
inicio de la invasión a Ucrania bajo las
estrictas normas de censura impulsadas
por el kremlin hace poco más de un año
de estas 482 al menos 136 han sido
enviadas a prisión recordemos No que al
principio de la invasión el código penal
ruso instauró Pues esta nueva ley por la
que criticar al ejército del kremlin
puede suponer hasta condenas de 15 años
de prisión al jazzira destaca 12 de
estos casos que han terminado en la
cárcel nosotros vamos a destacar cinco
de ellos vamos a empezar con un concejal
del ayuntamiento de Moscú concretamente
es Alex que fue el primer caso que
terminó en prisión por emitir presuntas
fake news él es concejal de Moscú y se
negó en un debate en el ayuntamiento de
Moscú a realizar un concurso de dibujo y
pintura para niños porque según decía él
los niños ucranianos estaban muriendo en
paralelo fue acusado de difundir esas
fake news y ahora es condenado a cumplir
una condena de siete años de cárcel el
segundo caso que destacamos es el de ir
ya yashing concejal también opositor en
el ayuntamiento de Moscú Aliado también
de Alexa y navalni fue condenado a 8
años y medio de prisión por transmitir
en YouTube un debate sobre atrocidades
del kremlin en bucha el tercer caso que
destacamos es el de la periodista María
Polo marengo que fue sentenciada a seis
años por denunciar en sus redes sociales
algunas de las atrocidades concretamente
ese ataque con ataque ruso sobre el
teatro en Mario Paul que se supone y
según los reportes dejó centenares de
víctimas civiles además de los seis años
de prisión se le condenó a no poder
ejercer la profesión durante cinco años
el cuarto caso que destacamos es el de
Dimitri ivanov un estudiante de
matemáticas de la Universidad de Moscú
que fue condenado también a ocho años y
medio de prisión por publicar en
Telegram esos ataques rusos e
infraestructuras civiles y denunciar las
ejecuciones masivas de civiles Y por
último destacamos el caso de Daniel
frolkin un soldado ruso que combatió en
Ucrania y anunció y confesó haber
participado en crímenes de guerra fue
condenado a 5 años de prisión
bien Vamos a cambiar de tema en Estados
Unidos hay un artículo del Washington
post que ustedes nos presenta hoy en el
que se advierten de los peligros de
utilizar la Inteligencia artificial en
contextos volátiles y el ejemplo pues es
perfecto todo ello a raíz de unas
imágenes falsas sobre el presunto
arresto del expresidente Donald Trump
que esta semana dijo que que seguramente
iba a ser arrestado no cosa que no ha
pasado no ha pasado de momento y toda
esta polémica crece a raíz de que
elliothings el fundador del medio de
investigación bellingcat estaba leyendo
sobre esa posible acusación de Donald
Trump Y entonces decidió que quería
visualizar esa posible detención
entonces recurrió a un generador de arte
de Inteligencia artificial y le dio las
siguientes claves Donald Trump se cae
mientras lo arrestan la publicó en
Twitter esa imagen generada por la
Inteligencia artificial y tituló esta
esta foto diciendo que
estas son haciendo estas fotos de
arrestado mientras espero a que Trump
sea arrestado él dijo que Solo bromeaba
pero las imágenes tuvieron una fuerte
repercusión siendo vistas por más de 5
millones de usuarios la conclusión Es
que la sofisticación con la que se
pueden implementar estas imágenes y su
potencial para crear ruido en medio de
las noticias volátiles al final genera
este tipo de polémicas y además se
deriva de este artículo del Washington
post una ausencia de estándares
corporativos y una regulación
gubernamental que aborde este uso de las
inteligencias artificiales para crear y
difundir falsedades por parte de las
redes sociales además destaca este
artículo del Washington post hay
políticas inconsistentes a todo este
sobre todo este tema destacamos una cita
textual de un experto de vigilancia
cibernética que recoge este artículo que
dice es la primera garantía visual de
que Trump es arrestado Incluso si no lo
es esta va la imagen que mucha gente
tendrá en la mente y aquí no tengo ni
idea Con qué me va a salir Marta para el
cierre una nota curiosa que publica la
bbc y que relaciona crustáceos con la
guerra en Ucrania la escuchamos sí
Ángela nos referimos a los camarones Y
es que la piel de estos crustáceos
contienen quitosano que es un
polisacárido que cuando se purifica se
puede utilizar como parte de un vendaje
para detener el sangrado cuando entra en
contacto con la piel este quito sano que
es lo que contiene estas cáscaras de los
camarones
seger se genera una especie de gel y se
forma un coágulo que puede detener ese
brote de la sangre el sistema de salud
de Reino Unido dice que este tipo de
vendajes compuestos con las cáscaras de
los camarones forman parte de los
botiquines de primeros auxilios de los
soldados ucranianos y que además han
salvado muchas vidas en este primer año
de la invasión varias organizaciones
benéficas
han mandado hasta 100.000 unidades de
estos vendajes y un dato curioso Es que
este tipo de vendas con crustáceos con
la piel de los crustáceos es ampliamente
utilizada también por los ejércitos de
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido pues le
agradezco mucho sabemos algo nuevo hoy y
las personas pueden ir y ampliar la
información en cada uno de estos
artículos gracias a usted y nos vemos
mañana la otra semana la otra semana
Ángela gracias